mr speaker why didn't the prime minister
sack the former
health secretary on friday morning
uh mr speaker uh we had a i read the
story in common with
uh you and everybody else on on friday
and we had a new health secretary in
place by
saturday uh mr speaker which i think
given that we
given that we have a pandemic i think
uh to move from one health structure to
the next uh with that
uh speed uh was was fast mr speaker but
it wasn't as fast
as the vaccine rollout mr speaker
uh which is which is now going so fast
that we've done
in this week half of the under 30s half
of the under 30s mr speaker
have now had their first jab and that
is speed stammer
mr speaker what a ridiculous answer the
price the prime minister must have been
the only person
in the country who looked at that photo
on friday morning
and thought that the health centre
shouldn't be sacked immediately
on friday the prime minister's
spokesperson said
quote the prime minister considers the
matter closed
minister after minister were then sent
out to defend the indefensible
yeah it was brief that the prime
minister was quite happy
for the health center to stay in his
post so
can the prime minister clarify now he's
got the chance did he sack the health
secretary or at any point
ask him to resign yes or no
uh mr speaker he though the the
honorable general will notice that the
the health secretary has changed uh in
the last five days
he complains about he complains about
the speed
uh with which that happened this
government moved to positively lightning
speed by comparison the right honourable
gentleman opposite who spent
three days trying and failing uh to sack
his deputy leader
uh mr speaker who he then who he then
promoted
who he then promoted mr speaker he fires
and rehires
mr speaker the deputy leader is sitting
beside me the former
the former health secretary the former
health secretary has done a runner
oh mr speaker on friday the prime
minister said the case was
closed then on monday he tried to take
the credit for the health sector
resigning
in a minute he'll be telling us he
scored the winner last night
but let me press the promise a bit more
on this the person the health secretary
was in a relationship
with was his non-executive director
let me remind the house according to the
government's own
guidance one of the roles of a
non-executive director
is to challenge the secretary of state
and the department to challenge them
and they receive taxpayers money for
doing so
so from the offset it was blindingly
obvious that there was a conflict of
interest here
and a whole host of unanswered questions
why on earth
did the prime minister judge that this
matter was closed on friday morning
mr speaker i hesitate uh to accuse the
right on
repeating inspiration i observe that the
non-executive director in question
is also uh no longer uh with the
department and what the what the
continuity mr speaker
is that that department is getting on
with the fastest vaccine rollout
of any uh of any european country and
i'm
proud to tell uh this house that uh this
week what does
that tell you what's happened just in
the last few days uh this country has
actually
overtaken israel in the proportion of
people
we have vaccinated mr speaker and i
think he might pay tribute to the health
department
for that achievement yes dharma so mr
speaker let me get this
right the prime minister was happy to
keep a health threat in place
during the pandemic who he not only
thought was absolutely
hopeless but he also you had broken the
rules
and was in a relationship with somebody
he was employing at taxpayers expense
it doesn't sound like case closed to me
and i know the prime minister is keen to
sweep this under the carpet
but let me tell the prime minister why
this matters
millions of people made huge and very
difficult sacrifices
to follow the rules that his health
secretary had introduced
prime minister take the case of ollie
bibi
i'm sorry you might want to listen ollie
died of leukemia
on the 5th of may the day before the
photo of the former health secretary was
taken
ollie died like so many other people in
this pandemic
with his family and friends unable to
spend time with him
when he was in hospital he begged to see
his family
but following the rules only one member
of his family
was allowed to see him his mum
said i'm livid we did everything we were
told to do
and the man who made the rules didn't
how can that be right
so i asked the prime minister again how
could he possibly think this matter was
closed
on friday morning mr speaker
we all share the grief and the pain of
ollie and his family
and millions of people up and down the
country who have endured the privations
uh that this country has been through in
order to get the chronovirus pandemic
under control and that is why we had a
change of health secretary
the day after the story appeared uh mr
speaker and that is why
actually what we are doing as a
government instead of focusing on
stuff going on within the westminster
bubble we are focusing on
rolling out that vaccine those vaccines
at a rate that will make sure that
people like ollie and his family do not
have to suffer in the future and i'm
proud to say
as a result of the effort as a result of
the efforts made by the nhs by the
department of health
uh by july the 19th we will have
vaccinated
everybody every adult over 18 will have
received
one jab and everybody over 40 would have
received
two jabs mr speaker that is the priority
of this government i'm quite right too
cursed armor mr speaker i can hardly
think that the prime minister thinks
it's appropriate in response to a
question about olly
to suggest that this is in his words the
westminster bubble
the westminster bubble in answer to that
question prime minister
before prime minister's questions this
morning i spoke to ollie's mum
about the awful circumstances that she
and her family have been through
she told me prime minister that every
day she watched the press conferences
every day they were on and she hung on
to every word
that government has to said so that she
would know what her family could and
couldn't do and then they followed
the rules this is not the westminster
bubble
she told me that for her and her family
this case
isn't closed and she speaks for millions
of people
ask the prime minister withdraw that
when he gets up
withdraw that when he gets up it is a
it's the wrong response
to olly's case i can't help concluding
that the prime minister didn't ask
relevant questions on friday morning
either because he didn't want to know
the answers or because he knows full
well there's more to come out
yes well then don't say he says nonsense
so i asked the prime minister in
response to his muttered nonsense
when he declared the case closed on
friday morning had he asked the health
secretary
if he'd broken any other rules yes or no
mr speaker let me be absolutely clear
with the right organ
and i think the whole house the whole
country can see that we have a new
health secretary in place
and i've had one since the day after the
stories appeared and that was entirely
right
and that it was and that was the that
was the right response to the
to the situation and he is of course
he's right in what he says about
the the sacrifice made by by families up
and down
the land but the best response in my
view to
their grief and their pain and the
sufferings that they have endured
is which is which is is to get on
uh with a new health secretary which is
what we have and
to with all the energy and application
uh that we have
to roll out those vaccines and allow the
people of this country
to work forwards towards freedom day
which i devoutly hope will come
on july the 19th and never let it be
forgotten mr speaker that if we
followed the advice of the right
honourable gentleman that would not be
possible because it was under his
proposals that we would have stayed in
the european
medicines agency have been unable unable
to deliver the vaccine role either at
all
yes speaker i really think that having
failed to sack the former health sector
he really is trying to take credit now
for the fact that we've got a new health
secretary so mr speaker mr speaker
well he would it wouldn't be there if
the prime minister had his way the
matter was closed
so mr speaker it's no questions asked by
the prime minister on friday
and no questions answered today there's
a pattern here
when dominic cummings broke the rules by
driving to barnard castle
the prime minister backed him when the
when the housing secretary
unlawfully approved a billion pound
property deal for a tory donor
the prime minister backed him when the
home certainly broke the ministerial
code
the prime minister backed her and when
the health secretary broke covert rules
the prime minister tried and wanted to
back him
too every time it's the same old story
isn't it the case mr speaker that while
the british people are doing
everything asked of them it's one rule
for them
and another rule for everybody else
mr speaker this gov there was a new
health secretary the following day
mr speaker now the whole country the
whole country can see that and we are
getting on
we are getting on uh with our agenda of
vaccinating
the population of this country through
the energy and application
of of the new secretary of state for
health and the department of health and
i thank them and i
and i congratulate it as a result of
that that vaccine row like mr speaker
which as i say
would have been which would have been
impeded had fatally impeded
how we followed the part the policies of
the party opposite
uh that we're able uh now to we have a
higher
wall of vaccination than virtually any
other country in the world and we are
able to proceed
with our cautious but we hope
irreversible unlocking
of the uk economy uh with the result mr
speaker
that growth is up to levels we haven't
seen since last july
jobs are up and he we cause it he calls
for us to he calls for us to act faster
in
in removing cabinet ministers mr speaker
it took him three days as i say
to give her three new jobs three new
jobs
shadow chancellor of the duchy of
lancaster a shadow secretary of state
for the future of work we create jobs mr
speaker
he creates non-jobs he divers we deliver